not take the the w why not he done what
has he done let's talk about some of the
people from some of the S States uh
Christine n of course governor of South
Dakota uh here she is on CNN going at it
with Dana Bash why not take the the W
what he
done what has he
done he's he's done nothing as far as
actual policies and actually using the
tools that he has I sat two days ago
with people that work for him that said
this President is tying our hands every
single day he does not let us do our job
this President we work for him we work
for the federal government and we hate
it we hate our jobs and we hate what's
happening to this country because he
will not keep us safe okay so she's just
saying what everyone knows No One
Believes the federal government is doing
their job and the Border agents there
are I I have great sympathy for them you
know these guys you you show these
videos of these guys opening up the door
telling people where to go and that's
not what they signed up for you think
when you became a border agent and you
go down to the Border in Texas or
Arizona for that job you think you're
like oh I'm just going to be a
processing agent and I'll just tell
people I'm like a travel agent really
like oh you came from Somalia and you're
in Mexico would would you like to go to
Chicago I'd love to send you there um no
I have great sympathy for those people
this is absolutely the fault of the
Democrat Party it's it's a bipartisan
fault because it's gone on for years but
at the moment it's the Democrat Party
that has the federal government right if
that's the President Joe Biden in charge
of the executive branch one of your few
jobs
dude